une deux trois jeunes femmes déjà connu
de certains téléspectateurs trois
visages qui très bientôt vont devenir
familier à tous à l'occasion de ses
débuts officiels la deuxième chaîne nous
a prêté aujourd'hui c'est 3 speakerine
denise fabre
bonjour mesdames michelle dos mais vos
journées de mauvais et rené le mot
bonjour messieurs une question
collective à être vous marier non
célibataire marié sans enfant veuve deux
enfants alors de mise
pensez vous trouver un mari grâce à la
télévision non avant d'être speakerine
et ils vous toutes les trois
téléspectatrice bien que faisiez-vous
avant de vous présenter à la deuxième
chaîne et bien j'étais déjà
téléspecteurs dans un poste privé et
bien avant de me présenter à la deuxième
chaîne je travaillais avec mon mari
en effet mon mari ahmed ça et des neuf
mariages il m'a appris à travailler avec
lui et ainsi je le second day dans
toutes les activités médicales
il ya j'ai travaillé pendant six ans à
la station régionale de la rtf
strasbourg j'étais comédienne
présentatrice d'émissions commentatrice
au journal télévisé régional depuis un
an j'étais comédien à paris et qu'est-ce
qui vous tente est le plus dans le rôle
de speakerine et bien avant de présenter
ce concours dont support est privé pour
accéder au titre de téléspecteurs et
bien agiter un tout petit peu mannequin
qui peut comme un coeur mais je n'étais
pas du tout fait pour ce métier et je
préfère de beaucoup le contact et donné
beaucoup de moi même j'ai d'abord pour
moi c'était tenter une aventure vraiment
passionnante et la découverte d'un
métier nouveau
et puis ce contact permanent avec les
téléspectateurs c'est un petit peu comme
si je les recevais chez moi d'utiliser
et de perfectionner les quelques
compétences que j'avais acquise à
strasbourg maintenant vous l'avez
exercer quelle est la tâche la plus
difficile de cette profession bien pour
l'instant je crois que c'est surtout
vaincre mon trac au la tâche la plus
difficile c'est vraiment de combattre le
trac je pense que c'est de ne pas
chercher à se composer un personnage de
speakerine devant la caméra c'est à dire
de rester soi-même et de conserver le
plus naturel possible
apprenez nouveau texte par coeur ou
improvisées bien
pour l'instant toujours et bien je crois
que je mélange un petit peu les deux
j'apprends les grandes lignes du
programme de la soirée
et puis si à l'antenne et bien je ne me
souviens plus eh bien j'ai improvisé
pour l'instant nous apprenons le texte
par coeur sauf évidemment pour les
annonces des excuses en cas d'incident
technique
jusqu'à présent j'ai toujours appris
mais mes textes par coeur mais il est
question d'instituer un nouveau système
de présentation où interviendra grande
part d'improvisation
réveillez vous et faites vous les
exercices d'auditions en dehors des
heures de travail bien j'ai pris
beaucoup de cours de diction au départ
je pense du moins j'espère n'avoir rien
obligé de ce qui pouvait me donner
beaucoup d'assurance à l'antenne mais
maintenant j'ai arrêté je pense que le
passage à l'antenne étant très bon
exercice chaque jour un petit peu je
m'exerce à lire tôt et puis mon mari me
donne beaucoup de conseils à votre avis
combien de temps peut durer une carrière
de speakerine cas moi personnellement je
souhaiterais toujours bon je crois que
c'est on ne peut pas fixer de limites
bien tant que cela lui plaît à elle est
temps que cela plaît à son entourage
je vous dis vous un jour faire autre
chose et quoi bien je viens tout juste
d'accéder au titre de speakerine rtf je
trouve cela merveilleux peut être plus
tard me compléterait ge je reviendrai
peut-être animatrice et je peux tu te
produire et peut-être moi même des
émissions qui sait et bien écrire pour
des émissions et surtout pour des
émissions de jeunes même d'enfants oui
j'aimerais écrire
merci de vos réponses mais où